[Music]
throughout recorded history there are
stories of leaders and free thinkers
that have been assassinated
political assassinations like these are
messy sometimes not fully thought out
events
many times they lead to outcomes that
the killer didn't intend sometimes the
exact opposite
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives five
experts discuss some of history's most
infamous assassinations and their
unintended consequences
we start now with the story of martin
luther king jr whose death did anything
but stop the call for civil rights in
the united states
when president lyndon johnson signed the
civil rights act and the voting rights
act in 1964 and 1965
the path toward a fairer more inclusive
future seemed clear
but soon after
many black activists
expressed doubts
malcolm x was one of the first to
question the strategy of
non-violent protests and civil
disobedience endorsed by martin luther
king jr
malcolm x promoted a new era of greater
militancy
he was assassinated in 1965
but successors such as stokely
carmichael produced a more provocative
vision of black power
it was about giving african-americans
political
cultural and economic power
and this threatened many whites
martin luther king worried that the
slogan black power
carried connotations of violence and
separatism that would harm the civil
rights cause
still
he acknowledged the logic in the term
in a 1967 book called where do we go
from here
king wrote
power is not the white man's birthright
and so it could not be legislatively
gifted to black people
the implication many drew was that if
power couldn't be gifted
it had to be seized
king was assassinated in april of 1968.
race riots broke out across more than
100 american cities
initiating a more
militant phase of black liberation
this caused a backlash among
establishmentarian officials who
vowed to re-establish law and order
to satisfy a white majority that had
become unnerved by black militancy
on june 28 1914 the heir to the throne
of austria-hungary the archduke franz
ferdinand had come to sarajevo the
capital of bosnia-herzegovina on an
official visit
a most provocative and painful date had
been chosen for this official visit june
28 was the anniversary of the serbian
defeat by the ottomans in kosovo back in
1389 when prince lazar had fallen
a 19 year old bosnian serb named gavrilo
princip was a member of a group of young
activists who resented the
austro-hungarian empire and dreamed of
some day uniting the south slavs that is
the serbs montenegrins croatians
slovenes bosnians and others into a
shared state independent of outside rule
seven assassins stalked the archduke
through sarajevo although one of them
dropped the idea and another threw a
grenade that missed
but when the archduke's car took a wrong
turn
princip leapt up to it and fired his
pistol twice within minutes the archduke
and his wife were dead
princip was arrested and tried because
the young man was just under the age
where he might have been executed he was
instead sentenced to prison and died
there of tuberculosis while the world
war raged
an international crisis escalated
austria-hungary accused serbia of
complicity in this assassination russia
came to serbia's defense then germany
supported austria-hungary against russia
also confronting russia's allies france
and great britain ultimately by august
1914 most of europe was at war
the assassination of president kennedy
shocked america and indeed the entire
world
most of us who were alive at the time
can vividly recall exactly where we were
when we first heard the news
i know i can even though i was only six
years old
witnesses in dealey plaza immediately
described to police a man seen looking
out the sixth floor window of the texas
school book depository from where the
shots came
and all points bulletin was sent out and
about an hour later a dallas police
officer named j.d tippett encountered a
man who matched the description
when tippett tried to question him the
man
lee harvey oswald shot and killed
officer tippett
oswald was arrested by dallas police a
few minutes later
but lee harvey oswald never made it to
trial
on sunday morning november 24th oswald
was being transferred by the texas
rangers from the dallas city jail to the
county lockup when he was shot on live
television by dallas nightclub owner
jack ruby
oswald died a couple of hours later
did you ever wonder why at the time he
was shot
lee harvey oswald who had just
assassinated the president of the united
states
was still in the custody of local texas
authorities
why wasn't oswald in federal custody
where were the u.s marshals
where was the fbi
yes it's true that oswald also shot and
wounded the governor of texas
and yes it's also true that oswald
murdered dallas police officer tipit
but that's not why he was being held by
the texas rangers instead of the feds
the real answer believe it or not is
that back in 1963
the federal government had no legal
authority to arrest or to try
lee harvey oswald for killing president
kennedy
the only crime that oswald could be
charged with committing was the state
law crime of murder
just as if he killed any other person on
that november day in dallas
now to be sure the federal government
did possess the power to make it a
federal crime to assassinate the
president
and congress eventually did just that
in august 1965
almost two years after president
kennedy's assassination
congress finally enacted a federal
statute prohibiting the murder
kidnapping and assault of the president
or vice president
it took the assassination of another
kennedy senator robert f kennedy in june
1968 on the night of the california
presidential primary to prompt congress
to extend the reach of federal criminal
law to include the murder of a member of
congress
we don't know how long it takes caesar
to die the greek historian appian tells
us that a friend of his named
artemidoris runs to the senate after he
hears about the murder and that when he
arrives the victim is still breathing
the conspirators original plan was to
carry caesar a short distance to the
tiber and toss his corpse into the river
had they stuck with this plan rather
than allowing his body to be returned
home
things would have turned out very
differently
this
along with their decision to spare mark
anthony is a blunder
in the end
they have too many scruples
caesar's funeral takes place a few days
later on or about march the 20th
we don't have a record of what mark
anthony actually says cicero the orator
and politician tells us that anthony
described caesar as a very great man and
a highly distinguished citizen although
cicero does not attend the ceremony any
more than does shakespeare
it may be a rather conventional eulogy
but it inflames the roman populace
anthony works on the crowd to the point
where they demand that he read caesar's
will which he just so happens to have
hidden in the folds of his toga
and plutarch tells us that when it was
revealed that caesar had left 75 denarii
to every citizen and had also bequeathed
his gardens on the far side of the river
tiber to them
an immense wave of goodwill and love
rolled over them
a 75 denarii would have been sufficient
for a family to live on for a month or
two it was a considerable sum in other
words
at this moment
all hell breaks loose a surging mass of
mourners breaks through the soldier's
cordon onto the rostra taking possession
of caesar's corpse and hoisting it on
their shoulders
the mob parades around the forum with
the dictator's body held high
the same man we witnessed celebrating
his quadruple triumph only a few months
earlier when he was the most powerful
man in the world
roman soldiers lining the root struggle
to keep the crowd in check
then a cry goes up that caesar should be
cremated in the forum rather than in the
field of mars as he had requested in his
will because caesar is the second
founder of rome
the idea gathers momentum and people
begin building a giant pyre in the forum
piling on everything they can lay their
hands on including benches and personal
possessions
soldiers donate their leather armor and
entertainers who performed earlier in
the evening throw in their fancy robes
ordinary citizens contribute their
jewelry
and then the crowd heaps caesar's
mangled body on top of the pyre apart
from the testimony about wide-ranging
schemes to terrorize the north the
prosecution presented evidence of not
just one plot against lincoln and the
other leaders but two the first plot was
that abandoned plot to kidnap lincoln
there were also evolving plans on
exactly how to pull that off
and getting him from washington to
richmond was never going to be very easy
either
as fantastic as it seems booth's initial
idea was to kidnap lincoln at
yes ford's theater
in samuel arnold's statement he said his
role in the plot would have been to
catch the president when he was thrown
out of the box at the theater
actor samuel chester
testified that booth tried to recruit
his participation in the plot beginning
as early as november
1864.
chester said that booth offered him
money in exchange for his proposed role
upon a signal to open a door at the rear
of the stage
by april of 1865 the facts on the ground
had changed to the point where success
for any kidnapping plot became all but
impossible
booth gave up on the idea of kidnapping
lincoln and began thinking about
how best to kill him
as it turned out the booth conspiracy
killed a present
but in so doing it made lincoln a martyr
booth and his accomplices hoped to be
remembered in the south as heroes but
largely their hopes were not realized
for most southerners the assassination
plot was an embarrassment
booth a well-known actor himself
may have opened his own play in ford's
theater that april night and it
certainly was dramatic
but it did not have the ending he hoped
for and few in his audience applauded
his performance
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes
of perspectives and you can watch
previous ones here